(playful music)
- I've had an absolute
fascination with sharks
since I was a little kid.
I knew I wanted to be a marine biologist
by the time I was five,
and I got to snorkel with my first shark
when I was about eight years old,
and I was literally hooked
on these awesome animals.
I'm Jillian Morris, I am
a shark conservationist,
a shark diver, and an
underwater videographer.
I've traveled all over the world,
and I have to say that
Bimini has some of the bluest
waters I've ever seen.
All different shades,
some people joke about
the 50 shades of blue in Bimini.
The island is really, really small,
it's about six miles long,
but the world just below the surface
is really what's incredible.
That blue, crystal clear water is teeming
with marine life, and is
the reason why we live
on this tiny little island.
The great hammerhead dive site
is about a quarter of a mile offshore.
It's a place where in very shallow water,
you're able to get in and
see these very large sharks
up close and personal.
It's very rare to actually
be able to be in the water
with so many of them like
we can here in Bimini,
especially in crystal
clear, shallow water.
Unfortunately, sharks get
a really bad reputation.
They're not man-eating monsters,
they're not mindless eating machines.
They're actually really intelligent,
social, incredible animals.
They're also really incredible
for the health of our oceans,
which all of us rely on every single day.
There's something really
special about hammerheads.
I have been in the water
with some very big sharks,
including great whites and tiger sharks,
but nothing compares to
the great hammerhead.
The way they move, their
power, their grace,
they can turn on a dime, and
they have those wide-set eyes.
They're my favorite animal on the planet,
and being able to dive
with them as much as we do,
I feel really, really lucky.
(gentle music)